at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking pronounce your son question now
it is see I'm a cybernetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
this episode is brought to you by
99designs when your business needs a
logo website business card thumbnail or
any other design I recommend checking
out 99designs I use them myself I've
used them for many years I use them to
create book cover prototypes for the
4-hour body which went on to becoming
number one York Times bestseller I've
also used them for banner ads
illustrations and much more with 99
designs you get a variety of original
designs from designers around the world
give your feedback and then pick your
favorite your happiness is guaranteed so
check out some of my competitions and
designs and some of your competitions
and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss
shell listeners at 99 designs.com
forward slash Tim and right now you can
get a free nine million dollar upgrade
on your first design so check it out 99
designs.com forward slash Tim this
episode is brought to you by gymnastic
bodies calm this is the training system
that i am most obsessed with at the
moment and I don't get paid any
Commission's or anything like that you
may have heard coach summer on the
podcast to design the program former
national team coach for men's gymnastics
I am not easily impressed and I've just
been completely blown away by the
sophistication of his programming and
the elegance of his programming i've
been using gymnastic bodies for just a
few months now and i feel more flexible
stronger and younger than I have in
years and it sounds cheesy to hear
myself say that but it's true that's the
hardest part to believe and you can
check it out gymnastic bodies calm
forward slash Tim if you go to that
landing page gymnastic bodies calm
forward slash Tim you can take a look at
the fundamentals course which I'll help
you diagnose your weakest points areas
to improve etc and I highly encourage
you take a look at this body weight
training system it is incredible
gymnastic bodies calm
forward slash Tim hello boys and girls
ladies and germs this is tim ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the tim
ferriss show where it is usually my job
to interview world-class performers and
tease out the habits routines tools
tricks etc that you can use this episode
is a role reversal I went to new york
city and i sat down with Stephen Dubner
of Freakonomics Fame and I was grilled I
was hit with all sorts of questions I
had never heard before her and we had a
blast doing it we had so much fun their
team did an incredible job with post
production and editing I wanted to share
it with all of you and you can of course
find Stephen and his team and his
co-author at freakonomics calm at
freakonomics on twitter and freakonomics
radio in the podcasts fear and without
further preamble please enjoy my
wide-ranging sometimes very odd
conversation with Stephen Dubner if you
don't try hard no matter how much town
you have there's always going to be
someone else who has a similar amount of
talent who out works you and therefore
outperforms its very easy i think in a
digital age easier than ever to confuse
being busy with being productive and
they're just not the same thing well
what if i did something with some more
passion what if I found something to be
a deeper interest to me I thought maybe
I should give it a go and see if it was
actually possible to improve let's start
with in 60 seconds or less what you
actually do in a given day if you have
such a thing as a given day I would say
interviewing experts tracking down
eccentric weirdos who are really good at
one thing or another formulating a plan
for some type of experiment involving
their observations or findings and then
recording it that is what I do most days
that is Tim Ferriss he is mmm what is he
exactly I am a human guinea pig and
professional dilettante
for our final self-improvement episode a
man whose entire life and career are one
big pile of self-improvement of
accelerated self-improvement as
evidenced by his book titles the 4-hour
workweek the 4-hour chef the 4-hour body
Tim Ferriss is in fact such a poster boy
for self-improvement that you might be
as I first was a bit suspicious I'd seen
your face and I knew that you were the
four hour blank guy and of course I
assume that you were total charlatan of
course right because that's how could
you not with a title like that Tim
Ferriss charlatan for self-improvement
wizard you'll be the judge as we cover
everything from his humble beginnings
very much the runt of the litter in
school and some rough patches so I've
had extended periods of depression that
I've become better at mitigating over
time chew his good fortune in startup
investing facebook also did very well to
the reason that millions of people do
every single thing that Tim Ferriss
tells them to do so the objective is to
provide you with tools and principles
for ten Xing your hourly output is there
anyone here who isn't interested in 10x
ignore our the output now I didn't think
so from WNYC studios this is
freakonomics radio the podcast that
explores the hidden side of everything
here's your host stephen dubner
tim ferriss recently stopped by our
studio with a head full of ideas and as
you'll hear a belly full of sardines I
suppose my professional life will be
split into writing books that all sound
like infomercial products most notably
the 4-hour workweek and then tech
investing so if you had to pick a noun
or maybe two to describe what you think
of yourself as what is the noun that
would be teacher I don't view myself as
a writer first and foremost I always
thought I was going to end up teaching
9th grade specifically because I had a
lot of really formative influences I
think at that fork in the road or a lot
of crucial decisions are made by young
books but I view my job as testing many
many different things performing
experiments and then providing the cliff
notes to people as a teacher not long
ago he also started a podcast which is
called the Tim Ferriss show now why'd
you want to go and do a thing like that
because we all know that podcasting is
not where it's at it was intended to be
a break between large book projects and
I have this nasty habit of writing long
books so the 4-hour chef was your books
are big 670 pages your books are so
weird in the best way they're not
narrative from beginning to end even
when they kind of feel a little bit like
those self-help books with boxes and
charts you were just zani in a way that
reminds me I'll be honest with you one
person with anyone else which was my mom
my mom was this kind of Brooklyn girl
who ended up in upstate New York trying
to be a Pioneer Woman and raise eight
kids and she did it she had to figure
out all this stuff and that's what
strikes me is what you had this intense
either curiosity or need or something to
figure out stuff and then tell other
people about it which is you know
generous of you where does that come
from why why are you not satisfied with
just being like everybody else I think
the answers to Fulton number one my mom
always encouraged me to march to my own
drummer so that was how how'd she do she
exposed me and my brother I've one
sibling and younger brother too many
many different environments
didn't have much money growing up but
they always had a budget for books and
my mom would take us to experience
things firsthand like go to the beach
and take leftover chicken bones and tie
them to strings and fish for crabs which
we threw back but the the list just went
on and on and if we grasped onto
anything and became really passionate
than she would and and my father as well
put all their support behind that and
secondly growing up I was born premature
and I was very very small until about
sixth grade AA small enough to get beat
up at recess until sixth grade I mean
very much the runt of the litter in
school and I was hyperactive so my mom
was looking for a solution to this and
threw me into kid wrestling so a kid
wrestling program weight class based and
i ended up embracing that is my primary
sport and got to national level towards
the end of high school and a big
competitive advantage i have is that i
studied the science of weight cutting i
got very good at losing weight and then
regaining it i was cutting from say 178
178 pounds 152 pounds which is how many
classes like four or five quite a few
yeah so i became an amateur scientist
and studying the various approaches to
weight loss and understanding what I had
to do to maintain performance so using
say potassium-sparing diuretics even
works but something available over the
kind of like a dandelion root and so I
think just to to provide context for
people that is where I realize the
benefits and risks and nuances of
experimentation you grew up in what many
people know as the Hamptons but not in a
lifestyle that was what most people who
think of the Hamptons think of the
Hamptons lifestyle right you were town
yes that's right yeah no white shorts
and tennis racquets would you folks do
for a living my dad was a real estate
broker and local real estate broker mom
was and still is physical therapist and
did you have jobs as a teenager and
stuff like that oh yeah I worked as a
primarily busboy at a place called
snowflake which is now boss twigs and
then the lobster roll a lot of people
know the lobster roll or they might call
it lunch but no
locals call it that it's the lobster
roll just now very well known because of
the show the affair you're how old now
38 and what is your spousal or
partnership status single single you do
have a dog though right Molly too I have
a dependent molly is nine or ten months
old she travels with you she travels
with me almost all the time and I've
heard you say that your food for her is
um dry kibble with sardine oil on top
drizzled over it right so I consume
after a conversation on my podcast with
scientist named Dominic d'agastino who's
a ketogenesis ketone expert began
consuming sardines in the mornings and
found that if I'm traveling in
particular I often give Molly dehydrated
say bison or different wild game when
I'm at home in San Francisco but from
traveling I can get her to eat dry
kibble with the sardine oil drizzle on
top of it and solves all sorts of
dermatological issues which i assume
correspond to other types of health
benefits internally right and did you
start eating sardines for the
dermatological benefit yourself or more
for the other components other benefits
right eat them every day almost every
day I sardines almost every day too to
the extent that i will travel if I'm
going to be gone for weeks I will
literally buy cases in sardines there
the rats of the sea world but they're
small enough that they don't
bioaccumulate as much say heavy metals
as something like an albacore i love
that story i hope it's true oh yeah you
know I'm choosing to believe that
narrative
Ferris majored in East Asian Studies at
Princeton but he was always looking for
business ideas as well he opened some
high-end gyms in Taiwan he sold audio
tapes of college admissions advice
neither those worked out he had better
luck teaching speed reading but he got
bored with that soon after graduation he
founded a company called brain quicken
which sold a nutritional supplement
meant to well quicken your brain and
then body quick which was pitched to
athletes Ferris says he was making a lot
of money but he was also badly
overworked so he took a leave of absence
went to Europe he expected the company
to tank in his absence it didn't did
even better without him which made him
wonder if the whole notion of working 40
and 60 and 80 hour weeks might be
overrated so your first book the 4-hour
work we got I am curious cuz I don't
know the word I'm looking for is not
fraud but i'm pretty sure you work many
more hours then four hours per week
yourself right so what was that a
prescription was it a wish or was it a
kind of metaphor for what one needs to
create with the objective of the book
for those people who haven't read it and
I'm sure many of the people have not is
to provide you with tools and principles
for 10 xing your hourly output and the
reason it's gained I think a foothold in
the finance world with people like hedge
fund managers also with people in the
startup world CEO is a very large
fast-growing companies is that they are
looking for sources of leverage right to
get more output for each input the
4-hour workweek title was one of 12
titles that I tested on google adwords
so i created campaigns to test the
respective titles and subtitles and then
just looked at the click-through rates
which went to under construction pages
and that performed the best of the
options that i have came in second
second ah was a better question what was
worst do you recall the levin worst oh
the worst i think and i had a lot of bad
ones but it was like broadband and white
sand or something wowser she's ball like
that
and but to talk about my sort of
personal perspectives that's the first
context and the second piece is the book
is not about being idle it's about
having control of your non-renewable
resource known as time then applying it
how you want to but the other kind of
misperception of the 4-hour workweek is
that especially because it's got a palm
tree on the cover right now the
objective is not to stare out into space
rubbing cocoa butter on your belly for
the rest of your life it's about
optimizing per hour but so the
implication is hey you don't have to
work so hard you can still accomplish
what you need to financially whatever
but the real message of the book is the
way that we think about filling up our
time with quote work which is often less
work and more just kind of garbage is a
silly way to think about the world it I
think that it that a lot of our
assumptions are erroneous and misplaced
and that we don't test them very well so
the part part of the reason that the
book initially took off in the text fear
aside from the fact they live in Silicon
Valley kind of right in the middle of
the switch box is that I talked about
measurables it was very much the
language of startups like what are your
KPIs your key performance indicators
what are the metrics that you're trying
to improve how do you do an analysis to
determine word focus and the it's very
easy i think in a digital age easier
than ever to confuse being busy with
being productive and they're just not
the same thing and doing something well
does not make it important so we sort of
drive towards efficiency and doing
things quickly oftentimes not stopping
to assess whether or not the things
we're doing are important in the first
place so one key piece of advice that
you and a lot of other people have given
over time is you know learning to be
better at saying no to stuff you know
especially as you start to succeed a
little bit at whatever you're succeeding
at in a firm as an entrepreneur as a
writer or whatever you know more people
ask you to do stuff and it's kind of
flattering and you want to be nice and
you I think the instinct for many people
is to say yes and all of a sudden you
realize that like eighty percent of your
good time is taken up by stuff that's
you know is not is not so good so
considering that you're a big fan of
know and considering that you said not
so long ago that when your goals for the
new year was to not do any media what
are you doing here
today this seems like this should be
exactly the kind of thing you should not
be doing well i mean the the goals move
around so they'd say there are two
reasons i'm doing it the first is that i
am enjoying working on my own podcast
tim ferriss shell and i think you're
extremely good what you do so this is an
opportunity for me to observe interact
and get better at what I'm also doing
good brown-nosing okay with my own time
so that's right so i'll start with the
flattery and then the second reason is
that with when I really drilled down I
realized the vast majority of my time
which I felt was ill spent was being
consumed by startups and so about six
months ago published a what does it
affect a resignation letter our
retirement letter I might celebrate
really yeah yes I once startup celibate
and then i should say these were
startups you were not participating
you're participating as investor
primarily correct or investor and
advisor which implies and carries with
it much more responsibility in terms of
being at the beck and call of various
founders or otherwise people related to
start up so that by stemming the flow of
say cold introductions via email and
what not related to startups i was able
to reclaim a large portion of the pie
that represented my total work hours
as an early investor in startups Ferris
had already had a number of what he
calls lucky bets was uber one of the
lucky bets uh definitely although that
stole private company Facebook was
enough facebook also did very well how
early how early were you anything years
before the IPO Alibaba Twitter about 20
or so other way that's 70 in total
probably and why'd you want to go cold
turkey on that was it that you had
enough money was it that you were sick
of that whole either group of people or
that kind of idea was it you just wanted
to change was that they going to do
other things well I'll give you the
short version mean it's probably a 10
page I wouldn't call it a scree but list
of real was a little scree d it was a
little screen yeah but the primary
reasons were number one I realized that
in today's environment I was in many
ways replaceable as an investor in other
words there's such a surplus of capital
that if I said no they're going to be 10
other people in line to say yes even if
the terms were outrageously unfavorable
and dangerous and if people were price
shopping meaning looking for high spell
you Asians or taking money off the table
and nothing more it made it very
difficult and unpleasant for me to do a
good job as a responsible investor even
from not using other people's money and
only my own the second reason is i think
the the dynamics right now in the market
are such that it's extremely difficult
from me as a single person doing this
part-time to filter the signal from the
noise and what I realized is I don't do
moderation well so if it's it till it's
much more effective in fact required for
me to say I'm not doing any deals period
0 I'm curious do you think that as a
strategy would be useful to a lot of
people in spheres having nothing to do
with you know investing virtually
evaluable yeah absolutely if you look at
behavioral modification and you look at
say the work of BJ Fogg at Stanford or
otherwise I think that cold turkey is
oftentimes and much more effective than
trying to titrate back and moderate
particularly when you're dealing with
compulsive or addictive behavior on the
other hand it may be that the people
that we learn about who were successful
at cold turkey
are the discipline people and that the
ones that we don't hear about so much
are the ones who try it and then
backslide a little bit and then they're
back to where they were oh for sure I
think there's absolutely the risk of a
survivorship bias right just like mutual
funds that advertise their performance
and in magazine a a B and C you don't
hear about the losers which is like a
Dow Jones look at the stocks that are in
the dojo right or we should all have the
ability that Dow Jones Industrial
Average has to get rid of the ones that
hurt our average right or the people who
are lionized on magazine covers for like
saying no to a billion dollar
acquisition offer and taking it to 20
billion well you only hear about the
losers because the story isn't as
interesting second sells many copies
Farris is what you might call a serial
obsession 'used at the moment one of his
obsessions is lucid dreaming so lucid
dreaming is very demonstrable in a lab
and it is the phenomenon of becoming
conscious of the fact that you're
dreaming when you were dreaming and you
can cultivate the ability to trigger
this which allows you to do some very
interesting things what do you need to
do whether physiologically or chemically
or whatever to prepare for lucid
dreaming well physiologically having a
basic understanding of sleep cycles is
helpful if you can wake yourself during
a REM cycle stay awake for say 10 to 15
s and then go back to sleep that will
oftentimes increase the frequency of
inducing lucidity if you wanted to get a
little out there there are some people
who take for instance huperzine a which
is an acetylcholinesterase inhibitor
prior to sleep in the belief that it
facilitates lucid dreaming have you
tried it I have difficult to say if that
is causal or placebo or otherwise but
seems to be a plausible mechanism
if I understand correctly you once
nearly attempted suicide I don't know
exactly what that means that's true yeah
at Princeton can you tell me do you want
to tell me a little bit about don't you
talk about it and this is this
experience I should underscore is not
uncommon at a lot of these pressure
cookers and in terms of universities
there was just a confluence of what I
perceived to be major negative life
events all at once including incredible
difficulty with senior thesis and thesis
advisor at Princeton and I approached
the administration about taking a year
off to focus on testing a few different
jobs because I felt like I was being
funneled into the goldman sachs and
Mackenzie's of the world then I knew
that wasn't a fit for me secondarily I
was like let me take the time necessary
to do a good job on my thesis and was
told two things first by my my senior
thesis advisor oh you're just going to
cop out this better be the best thesis
I've ever seen or in fact I'm going to
give you a bad grade which is a huge
percentage of your departmental GPA for
the entire time in your undergraduate
education and then secondly when I went
to the people I thought would be willing
to help because of this purported focus
on undergraduate education and health
and whatnot I was told and no in certain
terms that that tenured professor would
never do such a thing and that was the
end of the conversation so I felt really
trapped in a corner did you plan it did
you envision it yeah I did were you
depressed I was and it seems to run in
the males in my family on both sides so
I've had extended periods of depression
that I've become better at mitigating
over time but the most important thing
that I have ever written i think is some
practical thoughts in suicide a long
post on this i really think it's most
important thing I've ever written I see
that you are are or have crowd funded a
study about treating depression with
cilla Simon right at Johns Hopkins is
that related to your own experience or
very much related yeah so I think that
and I'm going to be doing more at Johns
Hopkins also funded some neuroscience
studies at UCSF and we'll be doing more
at the number of different universities
most likely including NYU
fact i'm curious having been depressed
and thinking about suicide in the past
how do you think about depression in the
future is it something that you kind of
feel your for stalling constantly or is
it not a feature of your daily life uh
it's not something i miss fearful of
anymore I think that I've identified
tools including judicious supervised use
of what we would typically call
psychedelics and theagenes just the new
branding perhaps that scientifically and
just based on the preliminary data and
published data have tremendous promise
for addressing treatment resistant
depression I mean beyond anyone's
wildest expectations that would be one
tools and I also think that that
preventive ly focusing on daily or
weekly habits that prevent depression is
really the ounce of prevention being
worth a pound of cure it's very hard
when your mind goes into this sort of
depression logic that is self-defeating
to pull yourself out of it so certain
types of exercise oftentimes related to
balance or acrobatics anything that we
are moving your body through space as
opposed to a weight around your body
secondly meditation I meditate almost
every morning for 20 minutes definitely
as well and less so in the evenings but
i do have mindfulness practices in the
evening and then nutrition there are a
few key sort of cornerstone elements
that if I control will not prevent me
from ever being depressed but will
mitigate it tremendously and what I've
also come to accept is I do think that
it's very common among people who try to
create anything original I think that
it's very hard to have the kind of manic
ups that allow you to see connections
between seemingly unrelated dots with
MAO and having some troughs it's I i I'm
not and maybe that's just rationalizing
and accepting depression but it's it's
very hard for me to find people in that
type of profession who don't have this
pendulum it's interesting because a lot
of people talk about the relay
ship between the two creativity and
depression but as if the arrow is
traveling in one way which is that
depressed people you know people like to
look at say look at 100 very very
creative people look at the incidence of
depression see it seems to be higher
than among the general population but
you're suggesting potentially i guess
that there's a causal arrow maybe moving
in the other direction which is if you
choose to be a creative type person
you're engaging in an activity of kind
of reinvent you know a blank page every
day that inevitably might produce highs
that might also be accompanied by you
know periods of a real mental drought I
think this is just from my own personal
experience and observations of friends
were also writers or songwriters or
whatever might be the more time you
spend in your own head I think the
higher just this probabilistically the
more likely you are to latch onto some
weird right circular reasoning but I
don't romanticize depression in that way
that for instance some musicians
fetishize drug use I mean well you know
you do your best work when you're on
coke and heroin and all this stuff it
brings out the muse and so on I think
that's a dangerous logic well I
appreciate your talking about it because
you know it strikes me as a huge paradox
suicide particularly but depression also
which is that you know suicide is is
rather prominent in in the West and
particularly in the u.s. you know more
people die from suicide than by murder
easily more than double and yet because
there's the taboo around it we don't
talk about it much in part for fear of
triggering it on the other hand the
downside of that is if you can't poke
around it something especially
empirically it's hard to learn about it
and hard to learn what you know leads
people totally I I do think in taking
kind of a left turn that if people spend
and this is going to sound simplistic
but the solutions don't have to be
complex to perceived complex problems
more time in nature and less reactivity
from all of the notifications and push
messages and so on that were bombarded
with and solves a lot of these problems
it really does it's like go lift heavy
objects and get out walk barefoot in
nature play with the dog and meditating
the
might be five with you dog one of the
reasons yeah one of the reasons get my
head on my own ass and actually focus on
something besides myself
coming up on freakonomics radio Tim
Ferriss answers our frequently asked
questions including what do you do when
a panhandler asks you for money I do not
give money and i'll tell you why we talk
about nutrition trends past and present
I mean like rice cakes might as well
just inject yourself with insulin and do
us a favor if you like freakonomics
radio tell three friends about it right
now go on oh wait Tim Ferriss is a self
experimenter an entrepreneur and
investor a writer he has a podcast
called the tim ferriss show he's tried
some TV I spent a period of time in
Japan for this ill-fated TV show did not
take off and I had a week to attempt to
learn Japanese horseback archery which
has to be pretty easy right horses can
sense fear and get spooked easily so I
have slowed down my breathing and remain
calm because if this horse gets it into
mine to throw me I'm not going to have
much say in it at all
not easier to try and pass yeah and the
galloping with no reins and pulling that
off your back and shooting at these
little targets the size of dinner plates
there was another TV show that also
didn't work out at least as planned it
was called the Tim Ferriss experiment he
shot a whole season 13 episodes for
network that later changed its mind in
each episode Ferris would spend just a
few days trying to learn a new skill
rock and roll drumming rally car racing
golf one episode was called urban
evasion and escape to tap into my inner
escape artist I'll be following Kevin's
lead and learning a broad spectrum of
skills how to escape custody blend into
my environment use the tail pick locks
and finally jump or boost a getaway car
the show was made for a new TBS platform
called up wave which got shut down
shortly after faris's show started
airing everything got put in the vault
and there was a regime change Simon are
you're out of luck but I was able to
license that back and distribute myself
on iTunes which was very successful
beyond my wildest expectations I was
asked recently by a network executive
you know what did you learn from your
various experiences and these different
media and michael has fund it yourself
if you don't finance it you don't
control it at the end of the day and
that has become easier and easier to do
with tools like Kickstarter with options
even for orphaned content all right so
Tim let's tackle some of our patented
frequently asked questions feel free to
give an expansive answer feel free to
give a lightning round answer there's no
right or wrong way to do these named the
handful or maybe it's more than a
handful of things that you do whether
it's rituals whether it's diet sleep
exercise whatever things that you do to
kind of keep yourself functional and
happy and moving forward every day yeah
I wake up probably yes or between
eight-thirty and 10am attend the stab
blade I sit down and meditate for 20
minutes
then I brew tea just typically poo air
tea with turmeric and ginger added to it
to which I add coconut oil just high in
medium chain triglycerides which the
brain likes very much I consume that as
I sit down in journal there are two
different journals that i'm currently
using the 5-minute journal just created
by a reader of mine [ __ ] really really
helpful for setting the tone and focus
for the day and then morning pages which
is really just a free association
exercise a good way to trap your monkey
mind on paper so it doesn't distract you
and sabotage you for the rest of the day
and between that point and lunch these
days I'm often skipping breakfast I will
focus on creative hopefully creative
production or synthesis so writing
recording exploring and if I have any
type of admin or housekeeping
metaphorically to deal with that is done
in the afternoon I'd say that's
generally the routine I every night have
a very hot soaking bath no bubbles no
jets that's sacrilegious what is one
thing you own that you should throw out
would probably never will the wooden
shards of the targets that I hit when I
was doing the Japanese horseback archery
you haven't displayed or just stuffed in
a drawer ah that they are respectively
placed on a shelf and I have no idea
what I'm gonna do with them I think I
might like you're gonna keep him I'm I
give him away to people at some point I
just they have such a strong meaning for
me that would definitely be high on the
list i also have notebooks since I just
the bookshelf and bookshelves of
notebooks where I've recorded for
instance almost all my work out since I
was about 16 I don't think I need those
what's your favorite sport to play and
favorite sport to watch favorite sport
to play competitive sport what is an
example of a non-competitive
isn't it then not a sport that's fair
enough no I arias to go well there's I a
related like kite flying although East
have kite fights and I was good ya know
acroyoga is something that I'm currently
really delving into it's a combination
of in effect yoga acrobatics and circus
Olay type performances ah the sports
that I am best at or have been best at
or generally those that I enjoy I don't
like being really bad at things so under
the club yeah you're visiting New York
now what you do pretty regularly it's
not uncommon to run into someone on the
street asking for money so it seems like
everybody over the course of their life
developed some kind of standard strategy
for that scenario what's yours I do not
give money and I'll tell you why I at
one point paid a homeless gentleman in
San Francisco to give me a tour of the
entire of homeless underground in San
Francisco would you pay it was through a
service called viable vay a ble is a
fifty hundred bucks something like that
and he was very explicitly said you
should never give homeless people money
and he showed me exactly where they know
right they guess for the homeless guy
who's getting paid by now so right it's
it's you have to take that into account
but he walked me through the Tenderloin
through all these different areas and he
pointed out where to get clothing where
to get housing were to get blankets
where to get food where to get all these
resources and he said anyone who is
asking for money is doing so to buy
drugs or alcohol Tim what is something
that you believed for a long time to be
true until you found out you were wrong
I believe for a very long time as an
athlete that that low-fat
high-carbohydrate was an obnoxious I it
rather yeah and I think there's a decent
amount of evidence circumstantial or
direct to suggest that low-fat diets
create a host of issues ranging from
joint problems to a memory I like the
cessation of menstruation I mean it's
it's it's I think entirely unnatural
force at entry people or for athletes
and also when you
people or discourage people from
consuming a thing whether in that case
it's fatter it could be you know
anything that you can think of it's not
like most people will instead consume
nothing they'll consume more of
something else to the compliment right
and in this case the compliment was a
lot of carbs and a lot of sugars that
contributed to if we believe the science
that we're reading today contributed to
all kinds of chronic and underlying
problems so absolutely i mean like rice
cakes much well just didn't check
yourself at insulin so i'm curious when
i read the 4-hour chef it strikes me
that you're a very adventurous chef and
eater but when i hear you talk about
your nutrition now i am curious what you
actually would put on a plate and put in
your mouth so if we were to leave this
radio studio and say hey let's go get
something to eat where would we go and
what would you eat I'm not pierced about
it because I also know how to
biochemically limit the damage that I
might create okay so if we want to go
out and have sushi need several pounds
of rice I could do that it wouldn't
cause me any existential angst but in
whatever your optimal meal we're in New
York choice optimal meal I would say
would be grass fed steak with vegetables
maybe some lentils from fiber that no
problem and I can go out and peep it is
not clear to anyone eating with me that
I am on a stranger restrictive diet when
i ordered a restaurant small question
here what is the best possible future
invention or discovery for humankind i
would best possible the first thing that
comes to mind is functional safety
precautions related to artificial
intelligence which i think is very
difficult assurance how do you create
sort of stopgap rip cords for an
intelligence that is by definition
intended to get to the point where i can
do several million hours of human
computation in the span of minutes or
hours so i talked to people that i read
about but it's really hard for me to
understand the contours of it but the
catch-22 part seems to me is we want it
to be good enough
to be so good that we would be secondary
we'd be the animals that somehow managed
to create a better intelligence and
therefore expendable yeah I mean it's uh
we kept at this is this is a very very
prevalent and intense conversation among
technologists right now and there are
those of course who believe that its
summoning the demon and so on there are
those who think it will be a panacea and
there are those who believe it could be
both I tend to fall in that latter group
I mean I do think that artificial
intelligence could solve potentially the
greatest dilemmas of our time which you
would name as what the fact that we die
too early the fact that we yeah you you
name it I think space colonization or
some variant thereof climate change
world hunger warfare or elimination
thereof I mean it's impossible to
conceive of not only the solutions that
a I would find to known problems but the
problems would identify that we haven't
even noticed yet I have no idea what
even the next five years will bring
though nai much less 20 years from now
maybe you do ah I have some guesses
which I probably can't talk about but i
would say that when imagine you can't
talk about it because you know them to
be true no because they're told someone
you won't break the promise that's right
the ladder uh just proprietary
information from from companies but i
would say this imagine that a nuclear
bomb were bits and bytes that could be
transmitted through any broadband
meaning replicable and scalable in a way
that's something physical like that is
not that's right that is far more
uncontainable than a closely tracked
amount of uranium or plutonium mm-hmm
that's a very sobering note on which to
n so that's not in there alright last
question if you had a time machine and
it sounds like you may know people who
have time machines when would you travel
to and why and what would you do there
so I'm tempted to say that I would
travel back in time to eliminate some
dictator or tyrant or so everybody I
think but I thought that people would
take care of that other people take care
of that so my knee-jerk responses I
would go back you can also go into the
future I'm just
I don't think I would go to the future I
would go back in time and have a lot of
drinks with Ben Franklin you do love Ben
Franklin I know and there's a lot of
reasons to love but tell me why him
because he wasn't afraid to be an
amateur and as an amateur with
beginner's mind I think a fresh pair of
eyes he was able to create many many
breakthroughs in multiple fields that
have shaped civilization in the world as
we know it today and he was also though
at the same time a bit of a merry
prankster and a bit of a showman and I
just really enjoy that combination being
able to accomplish very big serious
objectives while not taking yourself too
seriously is something I aspire to well
done Tim Ferriss thanks for coming in
thank you hey guys this is Tim again
just a few more things before you take
off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email for me every Friday then that
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and five bullet friday is a
very short email where i share the
coolest things i've found or that i've
been pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do it could include
favorite articles that i have read and
that I've shared with my close friends
for instance and it's very short it's
just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to four hour work week dot com
that's four hour work week com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by
gymnastic bodies calm this is the
training system that i am most obsessed
with at the moment and I don't get paid
any Commission's or anything like that
you may have heard coach summer on the
podcast to design the program former
national team coach for men's gymnastics
I am not easily impressed and I've just
been completely blown away by the
sophistication of his programming and
the elegance of his programming i've
been using gymnastic bodies for just a
few months now and i feel more flexible
stronger and younger than I have in
years and it sounds cheesy to hear
myself say that but it's true that's the
hardest part to believe and you can
check it out gymnastic bodies calm
forward slash Tim if you go to that
landing page gymnastic bodies calm
forward slash Tim you can take a look at
the fundamentals course which I'll have
you diagnose your weakest points areas
to improve etc and I highly encourage
you take a look at this body weight
training system it is incredible
gymnastic bodies calm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs when your business needs a
logo website business card thumbnail any
other design I recommend checking out
99designs I use them myself I've used
them for many years I use them to create
book cover prototypes for the 4-hour
body which went on to becoming number
one York Times bestseller I've also used
them for banner ads illustrations and
much more with 99 designs you get a
variety of original designs from
designers around the world give your
feedback and then pick your favorite
your happiness is guaranteed so check
out some of my competitions and designs
and some of your competitions and
designs from fellow Tim Ferriss shell
listeners at 99 designs.com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free 99 dollar upgrade on your first
design so check it out 99 designs.com
forward slash tim and until next time
thank you for listening
you